le palmarès du 30e festival de cannes a
été accueilli sans patient le festival
77 s'est donc achevée comme il avait
commencé comme il avait vécu dans une
certaine morosité je vous rappelle que
la palme d'or est allé au film italien
padre padrone et de paulo et vitolio
taviani un choix très discutée
d'ailleurs notre confrère le ror par le
même ce matin d'un palmarès en forme de
nécrologie mais il est un côté oublier
un aspect méconnu du festival de cannes
les incidences politiques de cette
manifestation un reportage de notre
envoyé spécial à cannes bruno masure le
palmarès 75 avait marqué le triomphe du
cinéma politique avec chronique des
années de braise ou encore section
spéciale l'année suivante en 76 le
festival avait amorcé une tendance qui
s'est confirmée totalement cette année
puisque cette année il n'y a je parle
bien sûr que des films qui sont dans la
compétition il n'y a plus aucun film
spécifiquement politique et cela est
vrai quel que soit le pays mais tous ces
films sont au deuxième degré
profondément politique simplement les
thèmes sont camouflés sensibles à
travers des destinées d'hommes et
surtout de femmes dans un environnement
historique précis la crise des années 30
le fascisme ou l'émancipation féminine
actuelle bedag avic tout film était
politique donc je dire que déjà de
mettre des films de femmes dans le
festival c'est un fait politique il y en
ad'autres veut dire vous savez ce n'est
pas forcément parce que on crie très
fort quand on fait de la politique je ne
crois pas du tout on peut le faire à
voix basse mais d'une façon tout à fait
efficace cela dans toute une série de
films lancé vers intimiste deux raisons
à cela ses films sans figuration et en
décors naturels coûte beaucoup moins
cher mais il y a autre chose on s'est
aperçus et ça c'est très révélateur de
cannes 77 qu'un problème politique ne
prenait toute son acuité que lorsqu'ils
passaient par si vous voulez le le
crible du bonheur individuel
je crois je pense que la politique quand
77 en natation point où la question du
bonheur et du bonheur pour les individus
devient peut-être le problème politique
numéro un et que c'est justement tout
ses films à la retraite de destins
individuels un homme une femme
et c'est qu'ils posent les peler
peut-être les problèmes politiques les
plus importants sont des thèmes assez
sinistre je dois dire de narcissisme une
espèce de cinéma métaphysique du
désespoir c'est même pas la vie
quotidienne c'est même pas le reportage
sur les malheurs quotidiens c'est un
malheur de vivre existentielle on
pourrait dire et ça va perdre parfois
très loin et je trouve que pour le
public c'est rude d'aller voir ça me
semble aussi je crois qu'on peut faire
un cinéma de désespoir qui débouche tout
peut-être sur des solutions sur quelque
chose de positif mais pour l'instant on
est au fond de l'impasse il faudra
certainement une réaction c'est vrai ce
30e festival reflet des inquiétudes
latentes a été un peu celui de la grande
déprime sur un fond de crise économique
mondiale très peu ou pratiquement pas de
sourire d'humour de sex-appeal de
souffle lyrique ou encore de happy end
bref une morosité certaine pas de quoi
contenter les 180 millions de
spectateurs français parents qui vont
encore au cinéma pour se cultiver bien
sûr mais aussi pour voir une histoire
vibrer et rêver cela à l'heure où on
annonce une baisse de fréquentation de
12 % pour le premier trimestre